back to sunday night in america let's go
back to january of last year democrats
had a nine-point lead on republicans in
voter identification polls 49 percent of
americans aligned with the democrat
party whereas only 40 percent identified
with republicans
january of 2021 was bleak there was an
attack on the capitol republicans lost
two senate seats in georgia former
president trump was impeached for a
second time
what a difference a year makes now the
tables
have turned 47 of americans now identify
with the republican party and only 42
percent were the democrats democrats
dropped seven points republicans went up
seven points
the question is why
why did this happen is it simply the
failures of the biden administration did
democrats overread the election results
are republicans offering something
affirmative or
just getting out of the way and letting
democrats fight each other
what explains this nearly 10 point shift
in less than a year
part of it for sure is the failure of
the biden administration
the feckless withdrawal from afghanistan
the fact that russia and china are more
emboldened than ever the mismanagement
of covet and supply chain issues the
border is a willful disaster
we were told biden was a foreign policy
expert but there is absolutely no
evidence of that
biden promised to manage the pandemic
but he has not
economic uncertainty at home and real
doubt on the world stage this helps
explain the shift and how americans
identify themselves but something else
is going on in this country there's an
existential angst about who we are as a
people as a country what we should
legitimately expect from one another and
from government
biden said he was a unifier and then he
went to a southern state when he
actually won to compare half the country
to george wallace and bull connor
americans are smarter than that
americans actually remember joe biden
himself eulogized a man who ran for
president as a segregationist
joe biden worked with and had very nice
things to say about other
segregationists
biden will tell you that these men
changed
well if men and women can change can a
state or a nation change too and when
that state or nation does change
why not acknowledge that why not
celebrate that
some democrats think people should be
able to vote without an id or have
political parties pass out items of
value to voters standing in line some
democrats even think prisoners and
non-citizens should vote
the rest of us do not
that makes us different but it doesn't
make us motivated by racial animus
part of what's going on in this country
is a renewed debate
over the scope and the role of
government
democrats want a larger role for the
federal government in areas like school
curriculum and health decisions for
children and child care and federalizing
elections
and americans are wondering why
government should be making decisions
for our children if government can't
even drone the right car in afghanistan
or produce enough cova tests or solve
the supply chain
americans don't want government dividing
school children into racists and victims
or a president dividing the country over
race
we don't want teachers unions lecturing
us about what's best for children when
they can't even bother to show up for
school
we don't want government telling us how
we should be softer on crime or let
career offenders out on bond because
americans are smart enough to know that
sometimes those career offenders
drive through christmas parades
or murder innocent young women in
california furniture stores
we want government to do those things
government is supposed to do
things like national security and border
security and public safety
so yes 2021 was bad for the democrats
and by default good for the republicans
if republicans want to turn a good year
into a good decade
then make the case for a limited
government that is competent one that
excels at core functions like national
security and public safety and the
border and the supply chain
if you can prove your limited federal
government can perform competently
and inspire a new public confidence
people may trust you to lead the country
and not merely lead the opposition
joining us now townhall.com editor and
fox news contributor katie pavlich it is
so nice to have you join us katie you
follow this stuff so well
so carefully
how what do you make of this shift in
voter identification
well i think we'd take we could take the
whole show to talk about all of the
topics that are driving the democrats
down the drain when it comes to voter
approval among independents in
particular 67 of independents now don't
approve of joe biden's handling of every
single issue whether it's covid the
economy
crime for example and this white house
has had this strategy throughout the
year of when there's a problem happening
whether it's the supply chain crisis
whether it's the testing crisis or the
inflation problem that we're having in
the country which is worse than it's
been since 1982 they say that it's not
happening or they blame it on something
else for example ron claim who is the
white house chief of staff said that
inflation was a high-class problem well
when you know everyday people are seeing
prices going up by eight percent on
everyday items at the grocery store
that's not a high-class problem that's a
middle-class problem and joe biden was
the guy who promised not to raise taxes
on any americans making less than 400
000 a year well inflation is a tax on
everybody crime affects everybody if you
have kids or you're a woman who wants to
just go to work as you acknowledged
earlier in the show and you're not sure
if someone's going to walk in the door
and and assault you or kill you those
are issues that every single person
thinks about and when you have a white
house saying and the federal government
and democrats ignoring the issue not
putting the department of justice uh
into a specific operation to combat
crime in these liberal cities not
calling up these da's in la and new york
and saying hey uh we have a crime
problem we also have a political problem
here uh you need to solve this pro this
this crisis uh people tend to think
differently about how they're going to
vote
katie you are so right the president
likes to blame republicans i'm going to
play a clip of him doing just that and
get you to react to it on the other side
and everything's changing
it's getting better
look um
i didn't over promise but
i think if you take a look at what we've
been able to do
uh you'd have to acknowledge we made
enormous progress
but one of the things that i think
is something that uh
one thing i haven't been able to do so
far
is get my republican friends to get in
the game of making things better in this
country
it's all the republicans fault why won't
they why won't they go along with
closing prisons and all the other crazy
ideas that have been put forward i
thought that was pretty sad what was
your reaction to that excuse
well again joe biden is rejecting math
in washington d.c
democrats have a majority in the house
and the senate
if joe biden wanted to get things passed
just with democrats he could do that in
a lot of ways but he is unable to do
that because he is unwilling to step
away from being a proxy for bernie
sanders and the left and when joe biden
took office in january of last year
there were warnings from a number of
people including moderate democrats that
he was too weak to stand up to the left
not just on economic issues but on
social issues as well and you've seen
that continue to play out and joe biden
promised on the campaign trail that he's
a moderate the media helped him in that
way so that he was going to get america
and the country and washington dc back
to normal and he has done the exact
opposite he took a big risk by trying to
become the next fdr with this big legacy
of massive government spending at a time
when he only had a 50-50 split in the
senate and he took that bet and he lost
and now he's blaming republicans when
it's democrats like senator joe manchin
of west virginia kirsten cinema of
arizona who are the ones who put the
brakes on destroying and blowing up
norms like eliminating the filibuster in
the senate all for the sake of pushing
through a very far left wing agenda on
the issue of federalizing elections
which the vast majority 70 of americans
don't agree with and so um you know
he is blaming republicans because
there's nowhere else to go and it's the
truth is that he has not been able to
unite his own party not to mention try
and get republicans on board with an
agenda that is not moderate at all it's
a very far-left agenda that's being
pushed by
the left in the senate and in the house
katie i'm going to have you on and i
will tell you ahead of time what i'm
going to ask you when i have you on next
whether or not november will be a
referendum on the size and scope of
government or the competence of
government i know you don't need to know
ahead of time what the question's going
to be but i'm going to tell you ahead of
time
i can't wait to have you back on thank
you for
thank you for joining us tonight
thanks for having me good to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else